hello good afternoon everybody and thank
you very much indeed for tuning in to
the 2015 senior virtual symposium I'm
Kevin Davis the publisher of caen en and
it's my great pleasure to introduce our
closing speaker after a full day of
great talks here nancy kelly this talk
will be a slight departure from the
dozen or so talks that you've heard
during the course of today nancy is not
a chemist she's a lawyer an economist by
training but she really is somebody
who's truly made a major mark in the
Biosciences field she led commercial
real estate development in life sciences
for many years finding homes for
multiple biotechs in and around Boston
and leading the development of the East
River Science Park in New York she
trunked that no pun intended by
conceiving and spearheading the creation
of the New York genome Center in
Manhattan a few years ago a truly
remarkable feat not just for raising a
hundred million dollars in initial
funding but also and I think even more
impressively for forging a truly
unprecedented alliance among all of the
leading New York academic institutions
to get that Center off the ground and
it's really flourishing over the past
couple of years nancy has turned her
sights to a new area the exciting field
of synthetic biology and today as she'll
present some of these scientific and
social opportunities that synthetic
biology represents and discuss the
logistic and funding models that are
probably going to be needed to realize
those ambitious goals our talk is
entitled engineering biology for a
sustainable world and it's my pleasure
to welcome now nancy kelly and thank you
for having afternoon i'm very excited to
be here and to be sharing on a topic
that i have learned a lot about over the
last couple of years in which i think
has great promise for the world so
as you said the title is engineering
biology for a sustainable world and this
really came about through the Human
Genome Project which was one of the
great feats of exploration in history it
was an inward discovery inward journey
of discovery through an international
research effort to sequence and map all
of the genes of human beings together
known as the genome completed in april
2003 the Human Genome Project gave us
the ability for the first time to read
nature's complete genetic blueprint for
building a human individual those
genetic instructions were contained in a
molecule called DNA and there are four
basic building blocks as most of us know
called nucleotide bases that are found
in DNA adenine cytosine guanine and
timing timing it is the sequence of
these nucleotide bases that encodes
biological information the cost of
sequencing that one genome was about
three billion dollars it took 13 years
to accomplish and today just over 10
years later that costs it's at about a
thousand dollars and can be accomplished
in less than a day which is truly
extraordinary development in only the
ten or so years since the human genome
project was completed now due to the
advances in the cost and speed of
sequencing DNA we've learned how to read
the genetic alphabet a cgt and see how
those nucleotides code for functions
with themselves this has resulted in
tremendous insight in using genetic
information for improved healthcare
delivery where patients today get
genetic screenings and personalized
treatment for a number of diseases now
we can read but we're just learning how
to write the next century will be about
how we write
DNA using those nucleobases or basic
building blocks to design and build
bespoke organisms that can provide
solutions to many of the planet's most
pressing global challenges you might be
tempted to think is already exists as
biotechnology biotechnology after all
harnesses cellular and biomolecular
processes to develop technologies and
products that help improve our lives in
the health of our planet we have used
the biological processes of micro
organisms for more than 6,000 years to
make useful food products such as bread
and cheese and to preserve dairy
products so what has our ability to read
and write DNA allowed us to do that is
fundamentally different now scientists
now envision using those four basic
building blocks of DNA to design entire
biological systems from the ground up
with as much precision as an engineer
can design a bridge think about it DNA
in its basic building blocks AGC team
hold the genetic code for every function
within an organism just like infinite
permutations of zeros and ones form the
basis for designing and writing software
code that drive all functions of
technology these nucleobases can be used
to write the genetic code for and build
entirely new biological systems from the
ground up the practice is called
synthetic biology or engineering biology
in the most recent vernacular the coming
revolution in engineering biology will
transform the industries of energy
agriculture health care chemicals and
bioremediation to name just a few and it
will also raise social and ethical
questions including what constitutes
life and what it means
Uman as well as important security
concerns about biosafety and by our
terrorism synthetic biology bridges a
number of scientific disciplines such as
metabolic engineering molecular biology
microbiology systems biology synthetic
chemistry chemical engineering and
genetic engineering it also relies on a
constellation of supporting technologies
like DNA sequencing and synthesis
laboratory automation design and
modeling software bioinformatics and big
data and computing in theory how does
all this work together to make biology
engineer abell scientists must construct
predictable systems and standardized
parts to do this they use computer
software to write the code that design
organisms in the abstract and predict
their production ideally you want to
design build test and scale up your
organism in a predictable modifiable way
the first part constructing predicted
predictable systems is done by
understanding how complex organisms like
e.coli or yeast work and stripping away
as much DNA as possible leaving only the
most rudimentary functions the organism
is now just a foundation a platform for
new DNA the goal is to create a platform
with well-known characteristics and
functions so new genes perform their
intended role without being disrupted by
other cellular functions once these
platform organisms have been built
scientists import standardized parts
readily understood sequences of DNA
these well known sequence code for
certain functions say color
or smell these pieces are stackable or
additive like Legos so an organism in
theory could take two blocks of DNA to
fluoresce green and smell like a banana
the idea is to build microbes and
systems capable of performing multi-step
processes based on different solutions
are different situations these are
simple examples and like software the
downstream applications are much further
reaching meanwhile the design in some an
assembly is done from a computer using
specialized software and DNA synthesis
previously DNA design and assembly was
done by hand but advances in DNA
construction and computer software
allows scientists to design their
organisms on a computer and get their
DNA made to order ideally these
functions could be accomplished by
machines in an automated laboratory
eliminating human era in the design and
assembly process and allowing large
numbers of genetic permutations to be
tried the engineering of predictable
host organism standardized DNA parts and
computer-aided design software has made
biology far more deliberate predictable
reproducible scalable and iterative but
the picture I just painted for you
presents the vision for this science and
we are still several breakthroughs away
from having truly robust biological
systems unlike machines living things
have unpredictable processes they evolve
over time and they evade our complete
understanding along the path to
delivering this new future there are
innumerable tools assembly method
standards and devices that must be built
many are still in the early stages and
oftentimes these tools have new
applications of their own like Chris
forecast 9 which is an engineering
biology tool that allows for very
precise in vivo gene editing but has
applications in many other areas
including the development of new
therapeutics well these systems may be
difficult to understand in the abstract
the applications are actually quite
powerful in reality one popular example
is the production of artemisinin an
anti-malarial drug with more than 1
million people dying from malaria each
year most of them under the age of 5 and
in sub-saharan Africa both access to and
the cost of the treatment remains an
enormous challenge normally artemisa
nick acid is produced by the wormwood
plant which has volatile supply and
comes almost exclusively from local
farms in Vietnam and Thailand that
cultivate the plant one of the leading
scientists in synthetic biology que je
kiessling engineered a new strain of
yeast that creates the chemical
precursor needed to produce artemisinin
cheaply and predictably by taking genes
from the wormwood plant that code for a
series of enzymes and tuning the
multi-enzyme pathway for efficiency
kießling was able to get the yeast to
secrete artemisa nick acid which is then
turned into the drug artemisinin with a
final chemical step the Bill and Melinda
Gates Foundation put 50 million dollars
into scaling up this product and worked
with partner in partnership with sanofi
aventis to produce the drug on a zero
cost zero profit model Sanofi has plans
to distribute the drug to 150 million
people this year
so our amusement is a perfect
demonstration of the power of this
science and yet as I mentioned earlier
there are many other applications beyond
health care such as an energy
agriculture bioremediation and chemicals
innumerable products from clothing to
plastics to perfumes are all made with
petroleum derived chemicals or with
specialty chemicals that have
environmentally destructive
ramifications such as palm oil companies
like ich / are using modified strange of
algae to produce palm oil which will
help reduce pressure on the rainforests
in Indonesia and elsewhere ginkgo bio
works is working with traditional
perfumers to design a cultured rose
extract based on numerous molecular
attributes that control for fragrance
other companies such as Jeanine core are
working to create a bio isoprene monomer
which will produce high quality
synthetic rubber without dependence on
petroleum based materials that cause
adverse environmental consequences due
to their high price volume ratio
renewable chemicals are likely to see a
large share of the near-term commercial
activity in engineering biology today
you're seeing price competitive products
derived from sustainable sin bio
chemicals in creams flavors soups and
fragrances applications in
bioremediation are a topic of popular
interest as organisms can be used to
clean up oil spills or consume
environmental contaminants such as
plastic modular genetics in partnership
with several academic universities
engineered a microorganism that produced
soy-based bio dispersants for oil
pollution management which could be used
to assist cleaning up environmental
disasters like the 2010 Deepwater
Horizon
oil spill in the Gulf rather than using
oils from trees grown in the rainforest
some scientists are also chasing the
idea of reintroducing extinct species as
a long-term project by reengineering
nearby relatives or by cloning replacing
the embryonic DNA of a nearby relative
with the DNA of the extinct species like
in Jurassic Park fiction turns into
reality as long as you have the DNA the
sequence DNA for an extinct species it
is theoretical possible to bring it back
to life and you may ask why we should be
concerned with reintroducing the carrier
pigeon or the woolly mammoth when so
many current species are threatened with
one in six species facing extinction as
a result of climate change since the
Industrial Revolution these efforts may
actually help to save species that might
otherwise disappear in agriculture we're
facing multiple challenges particularly
the exponential increase in human
population pegged against a linear
increase in food production some early
companies are targeting ways to
cultivate a better and safer food system
Clara foods for example has produced egg
whites in the laboratory using yeast
that does not require the cost in time
spent raising chickens newfree is
working on synthetic milk made from
yeast cultures modern meadow is
developing cultured food products that
do not rely on animals in collaboration
with well-known chefs there are also
near-term applications for engineering
biology and pest management to control
deadly diseases and protect food crops
dengue fever a mosquito-borne disease
affects over 50 million people in
tropical areas
of the globe each year it is estimated
to cost the global economy 5 billion
dollars per year there is no medication
or vaccine for dengue the only way to
control the disease is to control the
mosquito that carries the virus a
company called oxy Tech has created
modified versions of sterile male
mosquitoes which seek out in mate with
females to produce offspring that will
not survive to adulthood thereby
controlling the mosquito population
without pesticides recently the company
announced that releases of the
genetically modified mosquito in a
tropical area of Brazil reduce the
dengue mosquito population by
ninety-five percent which was well below
the threshold for epidemic disease
transmission and finally renewable
energy from non petroleum based sources
remains the largest promise and to date
the most elusive to achieve numerous
companies such as amorous and solazyme
raised a lot of money on the promise of
leveraging advances in biology that
would drive renewable energy so far they
have had to scale back their efforts
because yields on renewable sources like
algae or biomass are still not scalable
or really price competitive nevertheless
amorous is currently selling renewable
diesel in metropolitan areas like Brazil
and renewable jet fuel with its partner
total all around the world even beyond
the applications I just talked about
which are about global sustainability
synthetic biology is also vital for
endeavors beyond our planet NASA as well
as space companies are using relevant
applications in these areas to redesign
plants to create ecosystems in space
engineer to reduce the effects of
radiation
in zero gravity in space detect life on
other planets reduce weight and create
new types of fuels and eventually plans
to colonize other planets but the field
is not without its challenges the first
is cost in technological development as
we've just explored the applications of
engineering biology are numerous and our
mastery over writing DNA will continue
to increase rapidly today the costs it's
at about twenty to thirty cents per base
pair depending on the length of the
sequence but I expect to see another
tenfold decrease in the cost of DNA
synthesis as companies like twist
bioscience and gen9 enter the
marketplace in fact the rapidity of
development is a challenge in itself new
ways of working are straining old
methods and as legal frameworks become
outdated quickly regulatory bodies are
slow to adapt and the public is
viscerally uncomfortable with having so
much control over the natural world on
the intellectual property side a tug of
war exists between an open-source
culture that wishes to democratize
science and those who understand that
patent protection is necessary to
commercialize development in the
acceleration of scientific development
consider again the various parts of
engineered biology the host organism and
the standardized DNA part in particular
many existing standardized parts have
been filed under open-source licenses
that make commercializing products
derived from these tools difficult but
necessary if the benefits from them are
to be realized many of our nation's
regulatory bodies are ill-equipped to
handle such advances as our many
international bodies for example in
regard to the release of modified
mosquitoes discussed
earlier there were questions about which
body should regulate the release of
organisms and ultimately the FDA
approved their release but the example
highlights the fact that agency's lack
the expertise to evaluate some of these
new applications additionally new
applications may span the purview of
multiple agencies in this case the USDA
could have regulated this or the NIH or
the EPA the speed of development alone
is one of the underlying forces that
drive some of the hurdles to this feels
smooth development the regulatory
landscape is ill-equipped to adapt to
this changing environment especially
considering the expertise that is
required to properly understand and
evaluate these technologies meanwhile
the democratization of science and
funding is allowing new entrepreneurs to
enter the market you are looking at a
glowing plant a project based in a
community lab in San Francisco that as
their name suggests wants to make plants
that glow in the dark their long-term
vision is to replace streetlights with
glowing trees thereby reducing co2
emissions by not requiring electricity
but for now they'll make small
glow-in-the-dark ornamental plants
glowing plant funded themselves through
Kickstarter in part by promising their
7,000 funders that they would receive
free seeds on to grow their own glowing
plants as compensation this sounds fine
until you consider the millions of
dollars of testing and trials large
companies often go through before
releasing modified organisms into the
environment these trials are designed to
prevent the release of potentially
harmful non-native species species into
the environment and yet the regulatory
infrastructure was designed to work with
these large agro tech companies and not
unknown projects in San Francisco
so glowing plants fell through the
cracks global competition is also a
concern because engineering biology is a
discipline of science built on a
different fundamental premise designing
biological parts and systems from the
ground up and the applications are so
far reaching the continued development
of the field will have a profound impact
on the economics of nations who pursue
this technology being able to engineer
the building blocks of life with with
such control has enormous implications
for future leadership and the nature of
employment over the next century one of
the risks facing the United States right
now is a decline in funding while
competing nations such as the UK in
China have pursued long-term coordinated
funding mechanisms aimed at advancing
the infrastructure that accelerates
fundamental and translational research
England for example named synthetic
biology as one of the eight great
technologies along with others such as
big data and robotics and animation
systems and has developed interagency
funding mechanisms with leading
universities and companies for research
as well as programs to address ethical
legal and public concerns the u.s. risks
falling behind economically if it does
not dedicate the resources to the
advancement of this science risk and
ethical implications are also an
important criteria or concern grappling
with the implications of such advances
can be quite daunting and this
technology raises concerns both old and
new the old fears have been around as
long as science itself namely safe
handling and preventive Maleficent use
since the discovery of recombinant DNA
in the 1970s which essentially marks the
beginning of the modern biotech
revolution
scientists have generally been at the
forefront of addressing issues of safety
starting with the Asilomar conference in
1975 for example scientists convened
with regulators to develop safety
guidelines and processes for
institutional oversight to date there
have been no accidental releases of
genetically engineered microorganisms
from laboratories today with engineering
biology scientists have worked to update
standards of safety especially around
preventing the synthesis of pathogenic
sequences and in addition safety
precautions are designed within the
organisms themselves as I discussed
earlier with the introduction of safety
switches that do not allow the organisms
to exist outside of the laboratory for
the foreseeable future the threats posed
are relatively small as the majority of
experiments involved transferring
well-known parts into well-known
bacterial hosts for use within a lab
well this industry has been generally
good about safety there are a number of
modern concerns about DNA ownership safe
release of new organisms and the
public's visceral uncomfortableness with
having so much control over the natural
world these questions of ownership will
not be resolved and today and will not
contend will continue to evolve as these
questions become more complex and while
there are many open ethical issues the
reality is that the technology itself is
ethically neutral like almost anything
else it can be used for good or for ill
the onus is really on the scientific
community and the public to ensure that
the field develops with these
considerations in mind one of the most
important synthetic biology techniques
to appear is called crisper cast nine
which many of you might have heard of
which allows for gene editing within
living cells
Western world has issued a moratorium on
using this science for germ line editing
which would make traits charitable yet
just recently a team of Chinese
researchers of which there are other
teams submitted a paper in which they
tried to edit out app attached a
potentially fatal genetic disorder in
non viable embryonic stem cells the
breach of the moratorium brings up a
host of ethical issues related to germ
line editing such as the possibility for
unpredictable outcomes and non-medical
enhancements of human beings as the
technology develops a focus on
pre-emptive ethical discussions will
become more and more essential to ensure
that these advances are used responsibly
so if this presentation has explained
anything I hope it is shown that
advances in engineering biology hold
much promise for the world engineering
biology will in our lifetimes have the
technological power to remediate many of
the world's imminent and most
intractable problems it is not without
challenges in risk however in
improvements in the modern world brought
about by technological change often
carry unexpected consequences the
challenges of our time still far surpass
our capabilities of solving them and
these challenges are not solely
technical if we are to create the world
we truly wish to live in we must work to
change culture and consciousness in ways
that often cannot be engineered in a lab
thank you very much I'd be happy to
answer any questions you may have thank
you so much Nancy for a fascinating and
very eloquent presentation on
engineering biology in introducing you I
neglected to tell the audience that you
are welcome to
submit your own questions and there's
still time for you to do that we have a
good 10 minutes for Q&A here so you see
the small Q&A button to the left of your
screen please click that and feel free
to enter any questions that you may have
and I'll do my best to to bring them up
and and deliver them to to get man sings
response Nancy a few questions of my own
to hopefully get you to expand on a few
of the points that you touched upon in
your presentation first of all the
nomenclature I spent a lot of time in
the introduction talking about your your
interest and expertise in synthetic
biology and then you tell me it's not
called synthetic biology anymore it's
engineering biology is this simply a
matter of semantics or is there
something more important potentially a
play here auto semantics and there is
much larger issues at play which is why
the field is increasingly turning to the
term engineering biology rather than
calling it synthetic biology originally
when the field was first being developed
on the term synthetic biology was used
as the term for engineering new
biological organisms on but as time went
on and the public debate and the need
for public education around these issues
became more important it was hard for
the under the public to truly understand
how something that was genetically
identical created in the laboratory that
was genetically identical to that that
found in the real world could be called
synthetic in fact they were both
identical and so they were both derived
from lessons that we learn in the
natural world and the word synthetic by
itself makes people think of things that
are artificial
and that's not entirely true in this
case and so I think we're moving towards
biologically engineered solutions rather
than synthetic biology although
synthetic biology is still being used
within within the industry okay thanks
very much that will come as interesting
news to the editors of ACS synthetic
biology of course one of the ACS is
leading journals and one of the leading
journals in this particular field no
word yet on if they're planning to
change their name Nancy my next question
is that there may be viewers who are
curious as to how you became immersed in
this field of engineering biology in the
first place and I know that you spent a
good period of time over the past couple
of years writing or researching a
producing a major report but looked at
the future of an alliance that some of
you is like me familiar with a sim book
one of the leading perhaps the leading
national consortium of synthetic oil in
engineering biology laboratories I
wonder if you could just quickly refresh
or or inform the audience's to of what's
in berk is what your mission was and
perhaps so what the what were the fruits
and outcomes of that particular piece of
research that you conducted on their
behalf pranam or the synthetic biology
engineering research center on it is a
virtual consortium of scientists and
academic institutions that was created
in 2006 as part of the National Science
Foundation's Engineering Research Center
programs and it was given approximately
60 million dollars in funding to pursue
fundamental research over a period of
ten years the original goals of the
scientists
academic institutions that participated
in sin burg were both audacious and
simple at the same time and they were
two one is that they wanted to prove
that engineering biology concepts could
well that engineering concepts could be
applied to biology and secondly they
wanted to build an industry around the
science that emerged from that in the
period of just 10 years they have done
that and we now have a rapidly growing
field in which there are many new
companies that are emerging and are
receiving substantial private sector
funding right now and when i left the
and sews in Berks funding from the
National Science Foundation will sunset
in 2016 because that is a 10 year
program and so when I left the New York
genome Center the sloan Foundation and
Sandberg asked me to take a look at the
future of synthetic biology in the
United States and in particular to
create a strategic plan for accelerating
that field and for perpetuating Sandberg
either in its current form and its or in
some other form that we might recommend
and so we spent a year doing a very
in-depth analysis of the marketplace we
attempted all of the community events
the field had grown from what had
started out with about 10 scientists to
over 400 scientists across the country
that met in a variety of organizations
and scientific meetings on we
interviewed over a hundred and ten
people from government White House
through the agencies to academic
scientists to UM
you know Dean's at the academic
institutions to a industry that is
working in this field on all kinds of
people we reviewed over 500 pieces of
scientific literature and one of the
things one of the biggest things that we
found in terms of looking towards
sustainability force in berk and a
strategic plan for the community in
general is that no one really understood
what had been created from sin Burke and
so they were asking why should we and
why should we make additional investment
if we don't know what the benefits are
that have been created with the first 60
million that was invested and so the
first thing we did was to write probably
the most comprehensive report of the
field that had been done to date it's on
my website and a summary of that report
was actually published in industrial
biotechnology in June of 2016 on we
published the strategic plan in June of
2016 in a commentary by me was also
published in industrial biotechnology in
that same month calling for a national
center for engineering biology that
would advance this field on create an
interagency funding process um and so
all the agencies could coordinate and
allow companies to continue to work in
important applications in this area so
that's the work that I've been doing
over the last two years since we
published the strategic plan we've been
working with the broader engineering
biology community most recently we
co-sponsored some important scientific
meetings at the New York genome Center
in Manhattan one focused on engineering
biology and creating a center around
that and the second called SC two point
oh
which is on the synthetic synthesis of
the yeast chromosomes which is led by
Jeff buca and it has involved 200
scientists from eight countries all over
the world so the work is ongoing right
now and will continue to have new
announcements I actually have an
engineering biology page on my website
that is following the progress of all of
this work and so and it also contains
interviews from many of the leading
scientists and industry leaders about
their thoughts and ideas about why this
field is important and what it means for
the world
thank you let's so just a couple of
questions I think before we before we
wrap up here given Nancy as I said in
the introduction you you you did
something absolutely remarkable a sort
of three years ago not just in
conceiving but seeing this the creation
the physical creation of a world-class
genome center right in the heart of
Manhattan with all of the leading New
York academic institutions and others
further afield participating both
financially and intellectually do you
see down the road potentially any sort
of similar Institute taking shape in the
field of engineering biology that yes
we've been we actually held a meeting in
April that was co-sponsored with the
sloan Foundation in the Woodrow Wilson
Institute we had 60 people from the
scientific community and industry
discussing the need for such a center
and I think the overwhelming consensus
was there was the need the meeting
summary again can be found on the
engineering biology page of my website
we had a follow on meeting in July as I
just described and one of the things
that has come out of all of this
discussion is that many of the
scientists who are not necessarily
associated with an academic institution
who may be citizen scientists who may be
independent scientists want to have
access to these facilities so that they
are able to use the tools of engineering
biology to create their own products and
perhaps build companies around them and
we could imagine an open source
infrastructure that could be accessed
from scientists all over the world that
would allow access to these design
engineering and synthesis tools as well
as data storage and ways to
share information using platforms like
the one that has been that has been
designed by stefan friend at sage so
there's a lot of potential in this area
and i think one of the things that will
move it forward most rapidly is the
definition of a grand challenge in this
field where scientists could actually
begin to work collectively and attract
collective funding either from the
philanthropic the private or the public
sectors
I just want to segue from that response
and and ask the final question before we
close we're just a few a few hours from
the the next Republican debate which
should be must-see television I wonder
how optimistic you are or if you see any
signs of encouragement about the future
of not just science funding in general
but funding for engineering biology in
particular what would you like to see
coming out of this upcoming debate and
amongst all of the candidates of any
party over the next 12 months I think
that there are some promising signs
obviously this is quite a controversial
field and there is widespread on
political positions across the spectrum
there are some encouraging development
so a bipartisan bill on engineering
biology in 2015 was introduced into the
Congress in January of this year it is
not an appropriations bill so it does
not have funding attached to it but it
would create on a federal program
focused on engineering biology supported
by an interagency funding process and it
would have a lot of components such as
public engagement public education that
is really required in this in this area
there's also been some movement in the
White House recently to create more
transparency in regulation and a call
for the agencies to actually have some
interactive discussions about rules and
regulations and the approaches that they
will take to regulating this kind of new
biology and the EPA is having its its
meeting on that call just shortly and so
there are some promising things that are
starting to develop and I don't have a
crystal ball about what's actually going
to happen
well nancy kelly the founder and
principal of nancy j kelly and
associates and a leading authority and
expert in engineering biology and life
science funding thank you so much for a
wonderful presentation and a great way
to round out the 2015 seen Ian virtual
symposium so thanks to Nancy and a dozen
other speakers who generously gave of
their time and delivered us a series of
fascinating and cutting-edge talks over
the course of the whole day today
particular when I thank my colleagues at
see me n and lab roots partners here for
working so hard behind the scenes to
prepare and put this this great to show
on we like a spiritual environment very
much and a particular thanks to you for
watching and the thousands of other
scientists and colleagues who tuned in
at various points during the day to take
advantage of this so all of the talks
will be available on demand through the
rest of the year through the end of 2015
so I hope you'll share the news with
your colleagues and encourage them to to
come back and undo those that you may
have missed we'll be back in two
thousand sixteen I can assure you with
some more virtual events on important
timely subjects of particular interest
to the chemistry community so stay tuned
for news of those for now and pristine
Ian my name is Kevin Davis thank you so
much again for watching and goodbye for
now